I think we're live everybody we're live
we're doing this right now
welcome to the 10th annual 10th weekly
livestream VFX livestream we have come a
long way together it's very exciting it
is very very exciting so there's a lot
of announcements today a lot of very fun
announcements and I'll kind of just go
through well I guess while you all roll
in I'll take a bite of my yogurt here
crunchy my crunchy yogurt delicious we
got bananas we got almonds of course
Greek yogurt plain and Christian we do
have the kombucha today this is the
Cayenne ade gt's kombucha spice up the
evening that'll spice up the morning
wherever y'all are from welcome from
around the world
guys we're doing this so today is I'm
very very very excited for today's
livestream Europe so as you all can see
there's a brain here in my c4d viewer
and basically what we're doing today
CG studio thank you for the super chat
y'all that is a super chat had that
enabled a few weeks ago how am i doing
I'm doing really well actually uh the
corridor crew is working from home I'm
very very happy to be working from home
because you know I do have a little
setup here and it's peaceful the doors
open the sun is shining through we got
our cats over here enjoying the day
enjoying the sunlight and oh goodness
I'm glad there's audio you scared me for
a second
but yes the cats are enjoying the audio
hopefully are you guys can you guys hear
me hopefully you all can hear me give me
some thumbs ups lagging super hard y'all
lagging is that just Manas right now but
yeah things are nice you know I've been
running training for a half marathon
I've been doing yoga been working out so
things have been things have been
fantastic honestly things really have
been I hope y'all are safe I hope y'all
are healthy but what are we doing today
we're talking about ways to get out of
writer's block and get out of creators
block because it happens all the time
and there was a period of you know a few
years where I was just super down and I
couldn't really create stuff and you
know it was very very frustrating for me
and I tried to I tried everything I try
I tried you know just forcing it just
writing and this comes to you know
drawing as well what do I draw what do I
create what do I render what do I write
I don't know
and when you sit down and do it it just
feels like you're pulling teeth you know
so what we're talking about today is how
to circumnavigate that thing called
writer's block or any sort of creative
block and I'm gonna demonstrate to you
guys a fun a fun way how I've been doing
it in the past and we can get really
into writer's block and you know the
effects of it and different ways to get
around it but I want to show you guys
one thing real quick so on my Instagram
I have a couple renders that I did over
Christmas break and specifically this
one here
right this is from a book this was
described in a book and when I was
reading this book you know it gave me it
just really intrigued me and it gave me
some sort of mental image and I was like
you know what I really want to take that
and create it because at the end of the
day I'm a director I love I love writing
I love directing and I would love to
maybe hopefully one day direct and adapt
a haruki murakami novel into a feature
film and this is from hard-boiled
Wonderland and the end of the world I
believe is the name of the book yep I
have it right here it's a fantastic book
one of my all-time favorites and this is
just a little excerpt from the book and
this was kind of the mental image he
gave me same for this right here it's an
underground laboratory entrance through
a waterfall so I was like that sounds
like the coolest thing ever I would love
to do something like that so I just you
know took that description as
inspiration and it actually doing
something from you know from text as
your your point of inspiration is a
really cool challenge and that's what
I'll be doing today is I'll be doing
another excerpt from the same book
hard-boiled Wonderland and the end of
the world by Haruki Murakami well time
favorite author and basically creating
that for you guys today I'll go ahead
and read the little excerpt as soon as I
get through a couple more announcements
so welcome everybody to the stream we're
doing it a lot of you guys are asking
for the Beatle challenge we did it last
week you know I provided you guys with a
bunch of models and we all took two
hours to challenge ourselves to make a
really cool render with a bunch of
models and I have heard you guys we will
do this at least once a month maybe once
every three weeks I'm not sure we'll
figure out the right timing for it you
know I don't want to do it every week
obvious
because there's a lot of different stuff
I'd like to explore but um yeah well
we'll do it again for sure and I think
this is a good moment to introduce and
announce a new little weekly challenge
that one of the mods on the discord
server came up with and I'll show you
guys that real quick so let us see here
boom we got the discord server it's
super fresh super fancy and we got a
couple mods that we added we got deer
and vinkle Nero patty polygon and so
Demonte really just shout out to all you
guys for spending your time helping the
server out
we've reached 500 members at this point
that's awesome I never expected that to
be a thing so super cool yeah we're just
gonna keep this thing going keep this
thing live keep it active and I want to
announce a one hour challenge basically
you guys it's on the honor system here
you have one hour to render you know
whatever we decide it'll be a challenge
that I'll issue out basically in the
next two or three minutes here and
you're going to post it here underneath
streams there's the one hour challenge
submissions that's locked right now I'm
gonna make it live let's see here let's
make this bad boy live
you know I'm I'm learning discord here
I'm learning I'm new to the old discord
so hopefully that's live now and
everyone can post their one hour
challenge submissions it is on the honor
system so it's on you guys just take an
hour post it in there now next next
stream next Saturday
I am going to announce like the top five
highest voted images so basically your
due date is Saturday morning at 7:00
p.m. I'm sorry
Saturday morning at 7 a.m. Pacific
Standard Time that way I can you know
wake up look at these things and then
announce the weekly winners right here
live on the stream will critique them
will go through all that and we already
got Kevin first carbon second Knowles
third you know you all are in there
right now that's awesome
thank you thank you yeah and the server
itself is getting a little nice little
overhaul we have the different roles on
the right organized in a nice way we got
modelers we got VFX artists in the house
we got programmers animators motion
designers all that good stuff so yeah
shoutouts to the new mods we got Darren
vinkle we got neo Patti Nero Patti and
we got polygons so Demonte has been here
since the beginning we'll probably need
some more mods a little later so you
know stay tuned for all that good stuff
in Christian thanks for the super chat
buddy I got you on that kombucha dude
that Cayenne ade appreciate you man but
let's read some y'all's comments let's
read some of y'all's comments here hey
click Sahib asks do you render separate
shadow passes and c40 with octane um
yeah yeah most of the time I do
I'll render a seperate shadow pass when
I'm comping stuff in After Effects like
for the Boston Dynamics video I believe
that was the case we rendered separate
shadow passes martial arts asks but one
hour is like okay you have already all
the models and just do the competition
how to model something text or something
render it in an hour maybe two would be
better
um we can you know maybe two would be
better we can feel it out um what else
you guys saying I don't understand
so yeah in terms of like you can get all
your assets ready alright but once you
start you have an hour to do the
challenge and the challenge thanks for
reminding me the challenge is here's the
weekly challenge y'all need to take one
hour to render a book that's it could be
a book on a table floating in the sky it
can be a book whatever it could be old
it could be new whatever you guys can do
in one hour you need to render a book
and even if you you know I know like
Melanie as an artist and she likes
drawing stuff because she doesn't have
any of these 3d programs you know she
might draw something but I want you guys
to create a book in one hour and post it
on the discord server under the one hour
challenge submission channel and I'll go
through the top five highest voted
submissions on the stream next week
alright the deadline is Saturday morning
7 a.m. Pacific Standard Time so I have
time to like look over everything right
look over all the submissions and know
the challenge is not for only cinema4d
users it's for blender it's for Maya
it's for literally anything I just need
you guys to create a book that's it that
is the challenge a book the weekly
challenge I will do this every week I
think it's a fun way to shout you guys
out and feature all of you all of you
awesome guys in this thing in this
livestream so um where are we where are
we so what is the theme for today guys
for those of you just joining we're
talking about getting out of writer's
block we're talking about breaking
through any creative block and how to
render something awesome how to draw
something awesome how to write something
awesome without getting stuck a lot of
people ask Oh what
I do I never know what to do so one of
the ways I get through this and we'll
talk about all the different ways or a
number of different ways that I've used
in the past but what we're gonna do
today is go through one of my very
favorite books here I already have like
a paragraph picked out and we're gonna
render the paragraph we're gonna render
this description that my favorite author
Haruki Murakami wrote and we're gonna
see we're gonna visualize it and see you
know what that would look like if we
created a scene from you know just this
text here so that's that's a another
challenge to you guys you know if you
love reading and if you have a visual
visual mind you know then when you're
reading maybe just take note of the page
maybe of the paragraph of some cool
description that your author wrote down
and try and create that try and draw
that because that's there's definitely
you know positives to you know taking a
picture or pulling up a picture online
and trying to copy that picture that's
literally what I did I mean I still do
that
I still do that when I drew I would look
at something awesome and I would draw
that I know I'd draw a picture or I draw
an artist's drawing or you take a look
at someone's render like oh that's cool
I'd like to you know render what this
person rendered and see if I can't learn
a thing or two during that process like
that's certainly a way to do it I'm just
taking it one step further right and
we're starting not from an image but
from a text description so yeah that's
it so I figured the weekly challenge
this week will be a book all you have to
do is render a book any program you want
deliver it by Saturday morning next
Saturday morning I'll talk about it on
the next live stream Milan hello from
Croatia I hope you are doing well I hope
you are healthy
thanks for the super chat appreciate you
appreciate all you guys thank you so
much anything else anything any last
announcements guys we've been doing this
for a while
yes I believe there
one last announcement for this weekend
only I am running a twenty five percent
off sale on all my prints in the print
shop so this is this weekend only
Saturday and Sunday I got these things
down 25 percent for you guys feel free
to go through noise green and light comm
the address is in the description of
this live stream right now yeah go
through here take a look at any of these
guys I figured that while everyone's at
home you know might as well get some
cool art to hang on the walls well you
guys are in in quarantine I hope
everyone is staying healthy but yeah I
figured I'd do that for you guys 25% off
all the prints in the print store on
Noyes grain and light comm slash shop
alright guys let's get to any final
questions before we begin and I'm gonna
read the paragraph from Haruki Murakami
himself here my favorite author of all
time and we're gonna render what we read
that is the challenge for today's
livestream all right can the render be
of someone reading a book well if you
can do in an hour
sure but the challenge here is just a
book that's it it's all we need to do
for the weekly challenge its rendering
book and hopefully this isn't too
confusing for you guys you know I'm kind
of announcing a lot of new stuff right
now a weekly challenge and then you know
the stream as well today so you know
leave any questions in the comments down
below just at at me down here so I can
see if you have a direct question Peter
has a real question
he just started with VFX how long did it
take to get confident with your own work
mm how long did it take to get comped
with my own work
well since 740 was the newest thing that
I've started
I'd say it took me about six months to
get confident with my own work in cinema
4d it was six months of constant
watching tutorials and doing those
tutorials and implementing implementing
those tutorials in my own way you know I
would certainly I'd copy the tutorial
but then I'd also apply it in a new way
for an effect I was trying to achieve it
takes time and you just have to dedicate
the time to get better and you'll
certainly certainly get better okay
let's begin here guys let's read let's
read a little excerpt on what we are
going to create alright so this is from
Haruki Murakami's book hard-boiled
Wonderland in the end of the world it's
an incredible book it's fiction I highly
recommend you guys pick up his work it's
so good it is so so good so I'll just
read this little excerpt here for you
guys and then we will get rendering okay
the gatekeeper retrieves a ring of keys
from the wall and puts them in his
pocket he yawns as he laces up his
leather boots they look heavy and sturdy
with iron cleats for walking in snow
my shadow lives between the town and the
outside and just as a quick note here
the main character was separated from
his shadow so he does not have a shadow
anymore his shadow is a separate being
and he's going to meet his shadow my
shadow lives between the town and the
outside as I cannot leave to go to the
world beyond the wall
my shadow cannot come into town so the
one place we can meet is the shadow
grounds a close behind the gatehouse it
is small and fenced in so I'm circling
all these descriptive little chunks here
it's small and fenced in okay take note
of that the gatekeeper takes the keys
out of his pocket and opens the iron
gate to the enclosure we enter the
shadow grounds it is a perfect square
once I'd backed up almost against the
wall in the center is an old elm tree
underneath which is a bench the tree is
blanched with age I do not know if it is
alive or dead
lots of good descriptive stuff here
Murakami is so good at that in a corner
stands a lean-to of bricks in a and
building scraps no glass in the window
only a rude wooden panel that swung up
for a door
I see no chimney so there must be no
heat that's where your shadow sleeps
says the gatekeeper not as bad as it
looks even got water in a toilet not
quite a hotel but it is a shelter care
to go in no I'll meet him here I say
still dizzy from the stale air in the
gatehouse cold or not it's better to be
out in the fresh air fine by me let me
bring him outside so the gatekeeper
storms in to the lean-to by himself I
turn it my collar and sit down on the
bench scraping at the ground with the
heel of my shoe the ground is hard with
lingering patches of snow where shaded
by the wall another really good clue as
to what we're gonna be rendering
presently the gatekeeper emerges and
strides across the grounds my shadow
following slowly after my shadow is not
the picture of health the gatekeeper had
led me to believe
his face is Haggard all eyes and beard I
imagine you two want to be alone
probably got heaps to talk about well
have yourself a nice long talk but not
too long if you know what I mean I know
what he means my shadow and I watched
the gatekeeper locked the enclosure gate
and withdrawal to the gatehouse so it
goes on you know there's a bit more
description in here I'm not gonna read
the whole chapter but yeah basically we
have ourselves a little square shadow
ground here with a structure a slummy
kind of structure in the corner there is
a giant elm tree that's kind of a live
kind of dead in the middle there's a
bench and you have character talking to
a shadow on this bench the ground is
frozen it's during winter there's snow
where the shadows are and everywhere
where there's not shadow the ground is
frozen solid anything
else there's a giant wall behind them
keeping them in the town it goes on to
describe what they're wearing and we'll
set the scene first we'll get the
lighting down and then we'll add the
characters last so that's what we're
doing is we're rendering that scene all
right let's get some of this yogurt and
let's begin has anyone read this book by
chance or does anyone know who who
rookie Haruki Murakami is
all right hmm cool ah yes I did
thanks to you I have mega scans bridge
going and we're gonna be using that
today so much appreciated all right so
yeah this brain this was just for our
thumbnails trying to make a thumbnail on
how to get out of writer's block one one
thing that really helped me get out of
my writer's block was I would judge
everything before I got it down on paper
I'd come up with an idea I'd be like
nope that sucks
gonna be too much money not gonna be
possible I come up with a million
reasons as why not to write what I was
coming up with and that was the main one
for me he's like once I got past that
like I just need to write just to write
um then it got a lot easier I started to
actually put stuff down on paper and get
excited about stuff I didn't care if it
was gonna cost too much money to make I
just needed to be needed to become a
better writer same for modeling and
texturing and everything you just need
to put the practice in get excited about
the stuff like you don't have to post
everything you can create just a crate
and have fun so okay let's get the scene
going I always make a little figure for
scale at first right let's drop a plane
in see ya I imagined it somewhere along
this size so maybe there's like an iron
gate around this thing and behind it is
a large wall so I'm just gonna start
moving these planes around and get
things in place
and then we'll come back in and start
giving things more detail let's add a
floor where we'll just make it another
plane
and then we got like a wall back here
this will just kind of be a greenish
brown color for now there's probably
some pillars in the corner here
of the plane there's a lean-to described
in the book in the corner here for some
reason I always imagined it in this
corner back here so if you were a person
how big would this thing be maybe that
big for the entrance it'd be maybe that
tall and something like that so that's
in the corner back here in the middle is
an elm tree so I'm gonna use Forester
for that so I'm using the book here as
inspiration I'm using its description to
just block the scene out let's see here
let's see the tree library does it have
an elm tree lucky for us it is in
alphabetical order and it does not have
an elm tree what does an elm tree even
look like let's Google elm tree
alright elmtree so we'll find something
similar to that
hmm an oak tree actually might be the
closest thing or a cork tree looks
pretty sweet let's go with the cork tree
for now I think is huge hmm maybe that's
just it's just what it is let's keep
going here there's a bench right so
they're sitting on a bench underneath
this tree
so I'm imagine the camera angles will be
something like something like this so
let's get a little little bench in there
a place holder for a bench bench is
probably that long sure something like
that
and we'll get this going like this and
that's our bench
something like that
and let's see this the shadow grounds is
sore sorry it's the almonds again guys
the shadow grounds is surrounded by a
gate and then you have a giant wall back
here which is probably a little bit
bigger
no one's gonna scale that thing it'll
just be like some really intense bricks
and yes let's save our scene goodness
let's save our scene hmmm episode 10
okay so we know the ground is kind of
frosty and cold we know that the Sun is
probably shining from back here because
they said in the book that there was
snow in the areas where the wall caused
the shadow or cast a shadow so it's
probably something like this some sort
of backlit scene like this
cool very nice very nice all right how's
everybody doing here
everyone following along fine what kind
of books do I read the most I love
self-help books books where I can learn
let's see what do I have over here I got
lots of Haruki Murakami books lots of
art books photography books books on
story books on dialogue lots of like
filmmaking books and stuff
cinematography um you know I got some
some nonfiction like stories uh unbroken
was a good one I mean there's a whole
lot of crazy true stories out there but
in terms of fiction Haruki Murakami is
certainly my favorite I really like
Michael Crichton as well he's great
alright
so people asking what's the topic what's
going on we are rendering an excerpt
described in Haruki Murakami's
hard-boiled Wonderland in the end of the
world and we're using this as a means of
inspiration to get out of any sort of
creative block or writer's block that's
just one of the things you can do is
render something from a book render
something from a text description
certainly you can you know copy any sort
of arts you know you see someone's
someone's art online and you say oh as
practice I'm going to try rendering this
or I'm gonna try drawing this obviously
you know don't plagiarize stuff but if
you're using it as a means of practice
you know or maybe it's an image you took
while you were on a walk or something or
you know you saw something cool take a
picture of it and try and render that
you know there's a million different
ways that you can challenge yourself to
render a whole bunch different stuff
all right let's let's do it here okay so
the lean-to that's gonna be a thing
we're gonna need to get that going but
let's um let's just like block in the
the shadow grounds here with an iron
gate and some pillars perhaps so I'm
gonna go over to qixels bridge here and
it's a really easy way to get these
models into my scene and like this is
something that I've had to do for a long
time so kueh thanks for finally pushing
me to get this thing going and set up so
we need like column or pillar so let's
just search that oh man this is so cool
I guess I really really like that so
we're only gonna see two of them I think
hmm
decisions decisions chapel pillar is
pretty sweet but there's only one of
them and hmm but I do like the overgrown
kind of feeling it has so let's do it
let's download this thing we need a gate
as well like an iron gate I don't know
if they have any gates on here hmm nope
not really
so we might need to grab something from
turbosquid or something see if they have
any gates um hmm 3d assets where where
would a gate be under I love this
website so much
let's see
this could be cool for the lean-to maybe
a gate some sort of gate hey this is all
good stuff oh yeah you guys recognize
this from the the first render I did
based off of the haruki murakami little
excerpts here was like the hands with
the gloves reaching in for this goal I
just cut the little horns off having an
issue now with hgr eyes being blurry
Ryker um yeah you'll get that certainly
if basically if if they're not like 12k
HDR is there gonna be a bit blurry so
I'll just show you real quick basically
you have an octane sky let's load in
actually let's mix the sky texture so
when you have a Sun and an HDR eye you
just have to click the mix sky texture
box there and you'll notice that my HDR
eyes are blurry as well you know they're
not super high res because they're not
really meant to be backgrounds they're
kind of just meant to light your scene
however if I choose one of the grayscale
gorillas ultimate skies 12khz our eyes
those ones will actually be pretty high
res because they're 12 K you know you
could probably use that as a background
but normally HDR eyes unless they're
pretty high res they're gonna look a
little blurry Oh 16 case your eyes and
still blurry in unreal so I can't speak
to unreal though that is a program I
really really want to start learning and
streaming is unreal because you can make
a scene like this and just have it be
real-time you know okay but let's keep
going
let's grab an EGR I hear like some sort
of overcast HDRI oh this is nice
all right
so we need to still find some pillars
here and a gate we also want a huge wall
so maybe for the wall that's just gonna
be like a normal texture and not a 3d
asset but let's see what they have when
it comes to walls here on mega scans
not much let's try rock and see if
there's anything under rock that could
be used as a wall
it needs to be pretty big
no let's try cliff so this might not be
bad but you could definitely climb all
this stuff if you were a really good
rock climber you know there'd be no no
problem keeping you down this might work
actually volcanic Dola right cliff we
can start with this and see where it
takes us
the scale is pretty massive yeah let's
let's start with this and see see where
it goes
[Music]
all right let's start downloading these
things let's get these things in cinema
4d and you know y'all guys see how fast
it can be so basically all you have to
do is export it and it should just pop
up in the scene here
and there it is there is our pillar
looking nice and we'll go in and just
make sure everything's kind of set up it
looks like we need a couple more also
it's not an octane material for some
reason let's um let's try this one more
time
I have this working yesterday
hmm well maybe we'll just have to link
this up real quick
I'm going to convert this to an octane
material
and mega scans you can't download them
for free though they do have free they
have about 50 free things to download
under the little free tab there's 55
things all this stuff is free
you guys can download all these assets
and all these 3d models for free and
maybe that's what we'll do for the next
people challenge is we'll just use free
models from mega scans and make
something cool but yeah let me just get
this guy linked up real quick
so let's see we want specular we want
bump we want normal
cool that's looking a little bit better
yeah we'll just get this guy in the
corners here of our shadow grounds nope
brendi region get out of here how do i
what I do what
what on earth oh god what have I done
Interactive render region okay yeah
that's what I don't want
so we'll scale this thing up
and get this thing lined up just right
I'm hitting s to snap the viewport to
the current object I have selected
something like that and we need to get
an iron gate around this thing but
that's just gonna be a lot of looking at
stuff on turbosquid so what we'll do is
let's see if they have a bench let's see
if they have a bench they do it's a very
modest bench sure let's do it all right
so we're downloading a bench let's get
the ground looking nice so they said in
the book it's kind of frosty frozen and
dry and there's areas where wherever
there's shadow
basically you have snow so we need to
get our lighting set I think I think
we'll probably do the snow bit a little
later but let's get the overall look of
the ground down first
and I'll be using our D textures for the
ground because they have the highest
quality photoscan textures that I'd ever
seen so I'll be using that in a second
but I'm gonna get a little bit of yogurt
almonds and banana hmm how's everybody
doing you guys good
final following along hopefully this
isn't too boring for you guys
hope you guys enjoy the process or maybe
you guys are working on something
yourself
Douglas the shrimp dougela the shrimp
doodles what am I making
so I'm rendering a scene described in
this book here hard-boiled Wonderland in
the end of the world by Haruki Murakami
and it's a way for me to get out of
creative block if I'm reading something
and I'm seeing an image in my head like
you know what I'll just create that so
it's a great way for me personally to
get creative and come up with some new
ideas so that's what we're doing all
right what do we say we're gonna do the
ground yes the ground with arty textures
the best textures in the whole world all
right let's see no search snow and see
what they got
yeah like look at look at these textures
guys these things are legit like this is
kind of close to what we're going for
I might be just a little too much snow
but good thing they got snow - and they
got snow three all right this one's a
bit much right this one's a bit much
maybe for the areas where there's shadow
maybe what is the snow - looking like
very similar to snow three man just
beautiful just beautiful
doing a book club stream man that's
great
all right guys we're gonna do snow one
because we don't have all the time in
the world you know I mean you know I'm
saying so I'm gonna make a new glossy
material drop it on the plane here let's
go into the node editor and let's just
start dropping some freakin textures you
know I'm saying we got ambient occlusion
we got bump color we have a depth we got
high gloss or just gloss
let's just go gloss normal and roughness
of course we're gonna drag all these
guys in who am I gonna use a vertex
painting with the shadow and snow
perhaps perhaps that might be the best
way to go about it let's um let's start
dragging and dropping these textures
here make sure to save your scene guys
and let's um
zoom in here and see what's happening
with the texture I'm gonna turn let's
see let's turn down the exposure all the
turn off our Sun that way you can guys
guys can get an idea on what's happening
down here so we got our normal map
plugged in let's get our roughness
plugged in we got our gloss plugged in
which is basically specular we got a
displacement map so let's drop this
displacement node in here and we'll drop
this displacement map in well up this to
4k resolution set the mid level to 0.5
and the height will go like 50 it's not
doing anything it should be it should be
but we'll see in a second here once we
start a plugin all this good stuff in
here and um let's finally we got the
bump map and we have color and we also
have ambient occlusion and basically the
way you set up a me and occlusion you
see how this is just a black and white
image if you were in After Effects you'd
put this layer above your color layer
and you would set this to multiply and
that gets rid of all the white and keeps
the dark parts so in this case we're
going to use a multiply node and pipe
that into texture one pipe the color and
a texture too and then the multiply will
go into the final diffusion pass and the
way you control this is basically by
shifting the gamma up and down so if you
look at the ground here let's find a
spot that isn't covered with the tree
shadow oh okay we're alive so if we zoom
in to this ground here let's let's
actually the scale right first so we
have basically like this dirt patch over
here I think it just needs to come down
by half so let's
grab the material here instead of UV
mapping we'll just go to I think OOP
flat does not work
I'll try frontal no no no cubic yeah
cubic is good you can see it tiling over
and over and over so let's just up the
tiles here so instead of one what if we
do point one I think Oh point one yeah
and now you can see if we get rid of the
tree you can see it tiling a little bit
but it's actually not bad and as the
size right we will answer that question
by taking a look at some of these sticks
in the snow
I feels pretty good to me you know and
alternatively we can also double up our
texture here and like make another
texture that is the snow or that is just
like mud or dirt or something and then
use a noise map to basically say
whatever's black B texture number one
whatever is white B just the dirt but
I'm gonna I'm just gonna keep movin on
here and roughing out the scene all
right dude yes the zoo zoo just set up
discord so we could take part in this
one hour book challenge so thanks for
doing that man thanks for joining the
server it's a really really cool place
to you know communicate with other
community members here and stay active
and stay creative we got 500 members
actually which is super freakin cool 500
members I never thought that that would
be a thing I had no expectations for
that so you guys are really turning this
thing around making it super cool so
let's um let's keep going here let's get
in close and see what we are looking at
so we have like frost on the ground this
is awesome you can see that the depth
map is actually doing something you know
it's puffing up the topology here
topography and it's tiling quite a bit
but from a low angle you may not be able
to tell yeah and if we do a high gloss
let's go into our material here alright
and I'm gonna right click auto arrange
so it kind of arranges things nicely
I'll just kind of
move these around a little bit so here's
a quick like time-saving like memory
saving tip here basically anything
that's black and white any map that is
black and white select all those I'm
just holding down shift and basically if
you change them from normal the type
here if you change it from normal to
float it's going to just recognize them
as black and white and not color and
since they're black and white anyway
let's see if I can show you guys an
example of what I'm talking about so it
says down here it says used free total
vram 2.8 three gigs but if I set this to
float that number should go down yep two
point six nine gigs so that's a good way
to save on your scene because very quick
quickly we're gonna kind of max that out
and I'll do the same for the that pillar
we have as well
so from 2.69 down to [ __ ] change here
2.3 awesome awesome awesome let's um
real quick take the plane and up the
segments here a hundred by hundred and
that's going to allow the displacement
map to really shine and have a lot more
detail let's try two hundred awesome
alright
blueberry welcome we're talking about
ways to get out of writer's block out of
creative block and one of the ways that
I've done it in the past is to render
something based off of text that you
read so I'm a I love reading I'm a big
reader Haruki Murakami is my favorite
author of all time he's got a book
called hard-boiled Wonderland in the end
of the world and in this book he
describes an area where the main
character visits his shadow because he
was separated from his shadow and as
shadows kept in the shadow grounds and
that's what we're rendering right now
based off of the descriptive text in one
of the chapters of this book so yeah
he's a great writer my favorite of all
time I think I've said that like 30
times on the stream and um you know he
really knows how to write I mean he's
incredible very descriptive very
imaginative so we got a scene here let
me grab his bench
and that's how easy bridges quakes will
bridge the best
hey welcome Spencer I am I am very glad
that you can join this as well glad you
finally made it
welcome welcome we're just chillin right
now making a cool scene from book all
right so we got our bench let's let's
bring this guy around and you know I
might switch the bench out a little
later for I'm imagining a different
bench in my head but you know I might
tweak this thing after the stream a
little bit but this will at least get
you guys an idea of you know how I how I
create something from scratch
so we'll get rid of that chair because
we have our bench here boom in the scene
[Music]
and the snow is not as reflective bright
as I want it to be so maybe let's just
go to the camera settings here the
octane camera tag and let's go to camera
imager and we'll take our highly
compression by default it's at zero but
I cranked it up so let's go back to zero
let's go into the snowy texture and I'm
gonna switch out the specular map here
and let's invert that and see if it does
anything I'm just going to switch it out
for the high-gloss version because our d
textures they come with different
versions of their materials here so
let's use the high gloss boom
and then I'm going to just up the let's
see the color diffuse here I'm gonna
drop the 8k version into there so it's
nice nice and detailed and since I
dropped that new specular in there oh
yeah it still stayed on float which is
exactly what we want
okay Ralph Mac Savage welcome my brother
welcome to the stream no burpees today
we'll save that for the live streams or
nothing there all live stream we'll save
that for the render challenges Ben thank
you I'm glad you're enjoying the streams
man these are super chill I feel like
I'm not you know working at corridor
everything is very uh high-energy super
loud really intense really fast when I'm
on camera at least you know so this is
the more chill version of that right now
all right
yes duan haruki murakami is a Japanese
writer and I do wonder how much gets
lost in translation what are the same
thing and cult no I didn't get to mess
with radical yet I tried the Maxon moves
one moves by Max one I tried that one
once it kind of worked but no I have yet
to check out the other a I motion
tracking software it's cool this for the
phone though
all right
let's keep going let's build out this
lean-to so I'm gonna go back to the book
here and see how he describes this thing
again
he says backed let's see you know in a
corner stands a lean-to of bricks and
building scraps no glass in the window
only a rude wooden panel that swings up
for a door I see no chimney so there
must be no heat all right
first we google a lean-to I'm pretty
sure a lean-to is okay a brick lean-to
okay yeah this makes sense
so something something like this here
okay so let's let's see what the old
mega scans got for us
under 3d assets brick so they have these
like panels and stuff which are cool
they have individual bricks which is
gonna be a little intense for us it's
gonna be a whole lot of a whole lot a
lot of stuff there so we're not going to
build a brick by brick but we will build
it wall by wall and we just want to find
the right wall Oh what happened
hmmmm these corner pieces aren't bad
all right so I'm definitely imagining it
somewhere kind of looking like like this
here
this medieval style
antique
hmmm let's try other real quick you know
this isn't bad right here like these
little walls and stuff but it's not
brick that's the thing here we go okay
this this actually is not bad this
little setup right here I think I'm
probably gonna go with that yeah let's
do it alright so we've got a wall we got
a corner let's just get all of these and
see what we can do and then we're gonna
kind of have to like chop it to make it
a lean-to and we need a roof we need a
roof so let's go let's just type in a
roof and see what we get
they have 3d roof tiles that is awesome
I don't think we need to do it
tile by tile but I think a texture like
this will work
I wish did like hey or something that'd
be pretty sweet
oh this is actually this is this is a
thatched roof
but I kind of want something with a bit
more texture to it
like this one's pretty sweet I like that
ooh wooden log wall that's that's not
bad that's not bad at all but I don't
think we're gonna get the tips you know
like you're not you're gonna miss out on
those tips I'll just go with the
weathered roof for now and let's get all
these guys in cinema and we'll build
this thing out
all right
all right we got everything exported
floating in
I should get some ambi music on I've had
these headphones on all day but with no
ambient music let's change that right
now and if you guys need some cool
ambient music I got an ambient for VFX
and editing playlist in the description
of this live stream right now so head on
over it's like my favorite ambient
tracks super good for focusing and
rendering also good for sleeping so
whatever you guys want to do okay
let's pause the OL the OL renderer there
and see what we're working with here we
have our roof we have our front door so
the only thing that exported what about
our side wall we need our side wall guys
oh it's still I think it's still
thinking
okay
let's rename some of our stuff we have a
pillar we got our bench we have our
front door we have our roof
all right so let's just piece this thing
together real quick
so we can make this store a little bit
bigger
yeah that's good and our roof will bring
in
awesome
all right to ads friggin [ __ ] with
the ads that's hilarious
Christian hey glad you've been like in
the playlist man it's one of my
favorites definitely a good one
all right for some reason I feel like
yeah we need our we need our wall our
modular wall let's export that
and I'm going to add like an extra
little back section
the textures I'm getting from quick sole
mega scans I'm using qixels for them
over to see 40 quickly
where's that corner piece where you at
assembly
where the heck did it go 3d assets was
just called walls Oni
there's like a brick oh here we go here
we go
yeah this stuff right here boom medieval
corner
so let's get this guy over here
and we just need to fill in like this
little section here so how are we gonna
do that let's think about this maybe
grabbing the roof piece like this piece
right here we can just cut that in half
let's try it let's try it
so are you guys watching the stream
though where are you working on
something while you're listening to the
stream leave a little comment let me
know
so along with the structure here I
believe they said there was building
materials or something next to the
building um
[Music]
building scraps yeah building scraps
good thing mega scans haves lots of
building scratch work and work yes I'm
from corridor I work a corridor I love
it it's very fun get to work with my
friends every day it's great all right
we got working well watching working on
school 3d stuff watching I'm rendering
playing some World of Warcraft and
watching Mikkel very nice working
everyone's working that's great that's
great
working watching and listening you guys
are awesome let's keep it up
so maybe we'll just like scrunch this
thing down
hmm yeah that mean I work I may not work
it doesn't look that good I wonder if we
can just like move this up and then use
bullying to chop it
I think I might do that
so I'm going to connect these objects
together and then I'm going to select
the roof spawn hold down control and
spawn a cube on the roof that way I can
kind of just slide this thing up exactly
in line with the angle of the roof so I
can chop the tops of these walls off the
little bullying actions so basically
let's say this is our a and we have our
cube is our B and if you select a and
hold alt you can come over here to this
little instance icon here and let go on
bool and then you drop your B in and
it's a minus B that's the way a bullet
works so you have your a which is our
wall and you're using the cube to cut
the wall right at that exact point so
it's a minus B and that's our little
lean-to and honestly if we let's see
let's see if we make this cube editable
and we should be able to get the Anchor
Point down just into the corner
there you go and slide it up just a
little bit basically you can kind of
adjust the angle of the roof together
with that cube so if we want the roof to
be more at an angle say like like like
that we can take the cube and rotate the
same deal boom and we have our little
lean-to and we should be able I'm going
to convert our materials to octane
materials it's gonna think down here if
you ever wondering is premier frozen or
I'm something uh premier is um c40
frozen just look down here in the bottom
left and you can see it thinking it's
material convert started dot that dot so
let it do its thing or quick P ghost
welcome welcome back we are making an
image based off of Haruki Murakami's
novel hard-boiled Wonderland in the end
of the world this is one of my favorite
books of all time and we're basically
using one of the paragraphs that
described the scene we're making right
here we're using that paragraph as
inspiration to create this scene right
here and that's one of the ways that I
can get out of a creative creative block
or writer's block especially when it
comes to rendering is making something
based off of text cuz you know I'm
seeing a lot of things that I'm reading
this book because he says he's a very
descriptive writer so I figured hey why
not try and create something based off
of the text that is causing me to see
something really cool in my head you
know we'll just make it here and see 40
so that's one of the ways that I can get
out of a creative block is by using
fiction or books as inspiration
oh and you guys can't see the bottom
left there you go it's thinking
okay so I believe it had converted the
images or it shouldn't have converted
the images let me check something real
quick oh is that why it's not coming in
as octane materials isn't because I had
my renderer set to standard man if
that's the case you just blew my mind
NOLs yes yes it makes me happy and then
materials remove unused materials so you
can clean things up a little bit
all right let's continue see what the
render looks like which collections of
arty textures do I have I have all of
them all of them most of them I know
he's come out with some new stuff
recently which I gotta get but yeah
they're the best they are the best
the book is hard-boiled Wonderland in
the end of the world
yes the same scene can be created in
blender you can use any program you guys
want to create the same scene any
program you desire oh I may have crashed
it here octane is thinking you know I'm
trying to push it to do more stuff yes I
am very much into video games currently
my probably the most played game for me
right now is Smash Bros I play a lot of
Smash Bros with the guys the office and
what else I love Mario Kart that is my
jam
rocket League love me some rocket League
I am still getting through death
stranding which oh man what a great game
what a fantastic game so beautiful pep
plays a I appreciate you man thank you
for being here thanks for checking out
the stream ok so we can pause our
renderer we know that that's working I
think we can move on to the wall let's
get this back wall going and I'm kind of
just blocking everything in I'll come
back and I'll throw in more details if
we have time like some building
materials around this thing like some
boards and some some like wood blocks or
something you know
all right so let's grab let's do this
test let's see if switching my renderer
to octane is the fix I need then I bet
you you guys are right this cliff boom
export export how long have I been doing
VFX for I've been doing VFX since
YouTube came out I think in like 2000 I
think it was one year before YouTube so
2007 or 2006 I'm not really sure I
started in Windows Movie Maker adding
muzzle flashes in macromedia fireworks
which is no longer thing anymore it's
basically just Photoshop you know and
then I discovered Video Copilot dotnet
and it was you know basically over from
there because it's the greatest the
greatest website for After Effects
tutorials there's some really really
really good ones out now but man was
Video Copilot
like the greatest for such a long time -
what an incredible website what an
incredible dude Andrew Kramer I think
Andrew Kramer if it wasn't for him none
of us would be here alright and you guys
noticed I don't need to do these back
windows or the back walls here because
we're only viewing it from this side all
right so let's just organize this we
have our building I'm gonna drop all the
building materials into that we have our
wall
stuff like our camera our octane sky we
can group that into a folder called
scene we have our ground
and we still need to build our wall here
all right
let's go back into our camera view you
can kind of set the scene a little bit
more once we let's get our tree in here
don't push this guy back a little bit
because I don't want them to be in the
foreground I say I want them to be in
the mid ground and the angle I kind of
want to take more of a distant approach
with it so I'm gonna go to a 24 and
let's scale the ground up a little bit
and if we were crouching down
if we were the cameraman crouch down and
be something probably here
all right
let's render this and see what it looks
like you guys doing all right everyone
do it okay let's get some leaves on this
tree
why do I have to after-effects tabs in
my play bar it's because basically one
is the most updated the other is 2014
After Effects which is the only After
Effects which supports a plug-in called
real real steady and it's a camera
stable aja camera stabilization plugin
and that is why I have two copies of
After Effects
so I'm not really digging the wall right
now and I wondered if the lighting can
be a bit better
I'm gonna rotate this tree around until
we get a light nice little like spot of
light on the bench yeah maybe something
like that yeah the wall not really a fan
of a wall right now
and there's not really it's difficult to
see the difference between the tree in
the wall the building in the wall it
needs a bit of depth so it could be our
lighting you know we really want to see
the tree we want to sit at the tree a
little bit maybe the wall can be a
brighter color I think we need to add
snow to basically the roof and
everything and the blanket the scene in
some snow
hmm because our characters are gonna be
sitting on this bench and we're going to
want to spotlight our characters a bit I
think there was a scene in like I was
there scene and uh what does that was
that a Wes Anderson movie um the hotel
movie grand Budapest hotel
there was a scene in like the courtyard
it kind of reminded me of the scene that
I'm thinking of right now
[Music]
hmm I don't know if I'm gonna find it
was it a cemetery or was it a park I
only seen the movie wants
ah this was it yeah this was it this is
totally the vibe yeah this is what I'm
imagining see how like the people are
clearly silhouetted you know based on
what they're wearing here the wall is
dark which silhouettes the headstones
and she's wearing the brightest color
obviously the ground is white from the
snow
so maybe we will kind of go with an
overcast feeling on this one
well Center our subject up and in the
Sun tab here the turbidity is what
controls the overcast feeling of the Sun
so if you notice down here you can see
these uh the shadows are pretty clearly
defined but if I set the turbidity to
like a four it's gonna even that out a
bit and if we go six it'll even get more
intense than the Sun sighs if we set
that to to maybe five no that doesn't do
anything we'll set that to one and the
power will go to three I'm going to use
this picture as kind of a reference so
this really needs to be brighter
but it could also be my HDRI image as
well so let's try and change out the
HDRI image for something a little better
mm-hmm man this is boo chime in all
right we kind of just want to see sky in
the background
that wall is not looking good
and the tree itself maybe you'll change
from cork tree to oak tree and we can
come down with it it's a little big or
maybe maybe just maybe for the sake of
aesthetic here we will go with something
that drapes a little bit maybe this one
I feel like we've used this one before
though okay red oak that's not bad
that's not bad at all
okay so we still want to silhouette our
subject and this shots doing a really
good job of silhouetting these three
guys are here they're Center framed
they're the darkest part of the image so
maybe that's what needs to happen here
is there also a little bit of haze maybe
a little bit of fog going on in here
and yeah I could actually add a color
correction node to the tree defuse and
maybe just get the brightness up
that's not bad
the rock wall is just one asset but I am
not liking it and they described the
wall in the book made up of different
stones and I thought this would work for
that but it's it's not feeling right to
me I wish you could search by oh you can
you can search by size that's great what
is the biggest 3d asset they have
yeah I mean I pretty much hit it so
maybe what we need to do is check the Rd
textures here and yes I am reading
Chatham glancing over here from time to
time it's difficult to do both but I see
you guys I've been taking my vitamins
every day staying healthy
alright so it's definitely a rock wall
here and I feel I feel like needs it
needs to feel right certainly and it
could just be a combination of like a
few of these or something but you
definitely don't want to be able to
scale it that's the thing the wall is
meant to keep people inside
maybe maybe a castle is what I'm going
for but these are all tiny it's
basically just a wall like this but a
lot bigger how big is this
yeah that's not big enough
yeah I'm not big enough hmm it's like
boulders you know made up of boulders
and stuff
I wonder if already textures has
anything let's see hmm
no no not that
these are all like interior walls
no no it's like stone that's not bad
that's not bad it's more of it that's
like more of a brick
that's definitely interior hmm all right
let's check Jamie says rock rock 15 and
eight or has go to rock 15 not bad not
bad
Rock eight not bad okay
I wonder if there's more of like a
boulder II kind of one this one seven
isn't bad
hmm
I think right now seven is the one that
is cool though with the greenery on it
oh man that looks mean maybe 12 is the
one 12 and 13
all right let's try mixing some of these
together we got seven and we got twelve
okay
so I'll select the wall hold control and
make a plane rotate it 90 behind the
wall and stretch this out
all right
yes I am imagining scene from a book and
it is the hard-boiled Wonderland in the
end of the world by Haruki Murakami this
is where the main character goes to meet
up with his shadow because they were
separated when they entered the town
okay so let's get this wall looking nice
I'm going all 8k on this cuz we're gonna
need as much detail as possible because
we're scaling this thing up pretty large
and yes I am certainly going for photo
realism here that's usually always my
goal
and again the diffuse is mixed with the
ambient occlusion using a multiply node
and you just put both of those in there
apply the multiply node to the diffuse
channel and you control the ambient
occlusion with the gamma of the on the
actual ambient occlusion layer and you
can see that our mapping is all off so
unfortunately octane has an issue with
its displacement maps and it's mapping
so that's just super unfortunate but
we're gonna load it in and just have to
basically control it from the material
window over here versus you know messing
with the UV controls within octane and
the displacement map I always set the
mid level to 0.5 and I'll set it to 4k
for now save the scene of course let's
select our material up here on our plane
and set this to cubic and it should even
out for us
Ahn's are welcome thanks for joining
all right that's obviously way too small
so we'll get this tile going back up and
let's get
it's gonna just place my map working
properly so for this we need geometry we
need subdivisions for displacement maps
to work so let's do if you hit n
followed by B on the keyboard you will
get basically this view here you can go
up to display and change your shading
modes to you know see what's going on
here with the geometry on your plane um
let's do 100 by what is this like 500
and we'll come in here and we'll adjust
the displacement 10 centimeters let's
try 50 centimeters let's try a hundred
and fifty centimeters
it still looks very plain I think it's
the top of this thing that's really
throwing it for me definitely not happy
with the feeling of this right now
and you can see how the shading makes it
difficult to see your scene so I'll
switch back to a shading style that
makes it a little easier and you can
also hide the sunlight from let's see
let's see no we don't have sunlight that
is fine
all right let's adjust the power of this
HDRI here give it a little vignette
um let's see let's just try adding some
fog just a little bit and I think the
sunlight actually allows you to do that
if you go to medium add fog looks like
it does it for you a little bit
yeah just a little bit
oh you all want to see some cats let's
see if we can get some cats where's
Gilbert all right it's cat time we'll be
right back
y'all just caught this guy from a nap
let's do it wasn't napping super hard
this is Gilbert he's like I don't know
how old is Gilbert like five five or six
months
oh hey melody how you doing
are you drawing today ah man he smells
good too yeah this dude this little dude
just like tears up my desk start walking
over my keyboard you know what do you
say anything to add no he's chilling
right now and the other cat Teddy's went
to the bedroom guy kills what do you
thing about the scene Gilbert that's Kim
everybody say hello she says hello
ah here another cat is on his way
this is Teddy he's a little bit bigger
than Gilbert justjust just got smacked
yeah they're looking outside and they're
so curious he's ready to attack all
right Cody good luck on your rendering
adventures
Gilbert wishes you look all right girls
I'm gonna get back to this Thanks all
right
yeah I don't know I'm just not really a
fan of the scene right now sometimes
that happens sometimes you're just not
feeling it
but I'm not done that's the thing is I'm
not I'm not finished with the scenes so
there's still work to be done on this
thing I think the wall doesn't feel like
it fits maybe what we need to do is add
some snow to this thing so what we could
do is let's see here we'll grab a dirt
node we'll drop that into the diffuse
and we'll crank the strength up to ten
and let's see the hmm see here
so I just want to get the oh you know
what it's probably not a dirt node it's
probably a fall-off node because I just
want there to be snow on the parts that
are facing the sky so that would be
normal versus 180 I think or is it 90
maybe it's 90 so if I were to do that to
a sphere you know you throw a fall-off
note on this guy
then you should go if you change it to
180 oh it's going from the bottom so
stuff from the bottom is white we want
to flip that around so these values need
a switch and the minimum value let's see
the skew factor basically something like
that is what we want and we can copy
this fall-off map and paste it into our
scene here and that should give us the
desired effect of snow on the top of
something yeah so now you just like mix
between the two so for octane basically
you have your diffuse map here right you
want to mix it you want to mix between
this color and say a white snowy color
you can use material for that but I
don't think it's necessary for us right
now
we'll grab an RGB spectrum node and yeah
it's 0.9 all the way through basically
white we want to mix that so we'll grab
a mix node we want to mix texture 1
which is our original rock texture and
we want to mix mix it with this white
RGB spectrum we made and we'll use the
fall-off map as the amount so basically
anything that's white is snow anything
that's black is the original rock we'll
paste that in and then we'll drag our
mix texture into the diffuse tab and I
believe it just did a thing so let's go
to fall-off minimum value we'll set that
to 0.5
turn off the Sun so it renders a bit
quicker and we'll get right up on this
rock here after it's done thinking
all right I'm gonna change this to like
blue so we can actually see what's going
on here all right so the fall-off map I
want to adjust this a bit more
that's the original that's with the snow
skew factor let's try 0.2
ha I wonder if you could just use the
ambient occlusion yeah it's not far off
it's funny all right let's go back to
our camera view here I feel like it it
needs well what's that cube that roof
cube okay there it goes so I'm not
really feeling this this pillar back
here so I'm gonna actually get rid of
that thing I do want to kind of surround
this place though it's very very very
similar to this kind of vibe right here
[Music]
and agreed the wall definitely looks too
even on the top so what are some ways we
can fix that maybe if we just have
instead of it being on a plane maybe it
should just be on a cube with a Filat so
I'll hold control I'll spawn a cube
right here drag it out push it back
delete the plane and drag our new
material onto the cube actually before I
delete the plane I'll just drag the
material from the plane to the cube
because we have some settings remember
we changed some settings on that and in
the cube I'll check the Philip and that
should be right now we should have a bit
of displacement up top there let's
render that and see what happens okay
that works but something funky is
happening with the displacement this is
it because we don't have enough geometry
yep that's why so let's see we'll do ten
for the subdivision on the fill it and
then we'll just crank start cranking
this up I think we had 500 and want to
give the top some subdivision and I
think we had 100 for that
but it's still tearing why is it still
tearing huh
maybe we just throw a throw it onto a
Kinect and we put still tearing okay
weird
maybe we just make it editable it's
still tearing I don't know the answer do
you guys know the answer huh
the mapping UV mapping or just shreds it
you
men
yeah that's that's not that's not right
hmm I don't know why it's it's shredding
like that
okay if it's a displacement map look at
mid-level yeah maybe littles at point
five right now no whenever I go to 8k it
probably won't fix it no that's not
gonna fix it
this is so weird it should be working
all right I tried clicking seamless that
didn't work something on the Phong tag
use edge break no I don't think that's
working yeah it's a mapping I'm on cubic
or now
hmm see this would work if-if-if octane
got their business together and fixed
the whole displacement issue this
wouldn't be an issue
because then I could just set the the
displacement or the UV map to box and
that would work here's the thing
look I'll set this to UV mapping I'll go
in here and basically give all of these
a projection map or texture projection
and I'll pipe this in to all of these
nodes here and in theory I should be
able to adjust the projection here all
these images I'm gonna take off the
displacement texture and I'm gonna set
this the box
and box will basically even everything
out I'm gonna scale it up with a UV
transform node
I also wish you to select all the nodes
and hit transform and it connects them
all man you automatically would be nice
it still is kind of doing it
that's so weird set the box sometimes X
Y Z 2 u BW works but not in this case
and yes I might just have to make two
objects side and top that might be the
way to go
bending a plane that could also work
but yeah as soon as I give this thing
just placement the displacement won't
scale with the image so okay let's try
this a different way troubleshooting
guys that is basically the effects for
you okay
let's select the cube hold control like
a plane scale this up up I'll set this
to 500 by 100 and we'll drag this down
onto the plane so we kind of have I
think it was cubic 0.2 by 0.2 yeah we
have our original wall now and we want
to bend this thing in the bend modifier
let's see here so with the plane
selected I'll hold down shift and Bend
is the first one we'll fit to parent I
believe or within let's see
let's syllabus
pause the renderer okay so this Bend
Deeley here it's always weird for me
it's always confusing let's make a new
scene real quick and see if we can't
just bend a normal old and why am I not
seeing it I don't know I'm not seeing it
you should be able to see the modifier
but it's not working for us for some
reason man just a bunch of tech problems
hmm
I'm having trouble here folks
yes
well let's maybe try something else
I think the quickest way to go here is
to just make a new one
something like that I'm gonna cut down
on some of these subdivisions there yeah
let's render it and see what it looks
like
this rendering this rendering away shoo
Freddie thank you dude it was a very
generous super chat thank you so much it
says hope we get through these tough
times and become the best and what we
love doing greetings to everyone in the
chat yeah thank you so much
how is everyone doing by the way is
quarantine going all right for you guys
is it is it okay is it more difficult
than you imagined are you guys staying
healthy during these quarantine times
Freddie that was very nice thank you so
much I really appreciate it ma'am thanks
for sticking in I can't believe that you
guys are having a good time watching me
troubleshoot here it's pretty crazy
it's a bottomless bowl of yogurt
ah man sometimes octane just takes a
minute we're gonna get back to this
scene guys once octane is done rendering
let me finish this thing up
yeah Jamie says he's been locked down up
for 21 days hearing stories can go on
for six months it might you know I think
we're all trying to it's a very tough
balance because you know for the economy
we want to get the stores back open get
everything going like it used to as soon
as possible but I feel like if you rush
out of quarantine as soon as possible
yeah pardon me um you know we're risking
a huge chance of it coming back so
there's this weird balance this fine
line that you have to play that no one
knows the right answer I wouldn't want
to be someone in charge right now having
to make these tough decisions because
we've never really been through anything
like this so I think it's tough for
everybody but hey look at that we got
the top of that wall with some texture I
think that's great
we did it
okay
this little brick structure I'm just not
a fan on a fan of the lighting to be
honest like the way I'm imagining this
in my head it's a bit different and we
still want to close in the structure as
well
a pep I am glad that this is informative
for you in educational I'm glad you're
down for this stream yeah thank ya
thanks guys hmm Trent's thank you thank
you for the super chat brother I
appreciate you glad to see a c4d artist
I love it so much
I really do love this program they make
it super user-friendly yeah it's just
great
I really like the you I like the way
it's laid out it's not confusing you
know the first time I open 3ds max I was
just like oh oh this is gonna be a pain
but with c40 everything is colorful and
happy and fun and it just looks awesome
and it I want to dive into all this
stuff so yeah yeah I love it - I'm glad
you're using c40 as well a mirror if you
stay in quarantine quarantine some more
you'll start learning blender why don't
you just start now
just start now you had the time come on
guys we have all this time we're in
quarantine let's make the best of it and
I'm doing all right
I am doing totally fine I still get to
go on walks which is really nice we got
to do yoga I go out for runs in the
morning it's very peaceful very very
peaceful it's quiet here I like I like
peace and quiet it's nice and yes
sidenote if anyone is looking to foster
kiddies or doggies during this time I've
had a couple co-workers talk about it
all of the shelters and different
organizations near you I imagine would
be very happy look after and have some
crazy fun animal time that makes sense
that's a good good thing to keep in mind
hey what do you think of this scene so
far though let me get rid of this dude
what does it need
- a cube on top of the thing mmm this
guy it's the same as the snow mm-hmm
yeah I feel like you need some depth as
well huh this is tough if you like this
one that I'll be working on over this
week as well thank you
and yes I watched Chris Schmitt he is
fantastic I've learned a lot from that
guy a whole lot from Chris I've met him
in person at nab we went to karaoke
together it was really fun so I think
there's a way to get snow on top of this
tree but it go whoa okay guys that's
that's the snow all right I don't even
know I don't even know
so I guess I'd like set these settings
beforehand geez
we had Therese now maybe we do the same
thing and we just kind of give it that
fall off
what's the best way to get rid of
fireflies um you need a large jar very
large jar but um no for real
fireflies those are the things that make
your image look all weird and crunchies
those white specks everywhere the best
way to get rid of those you go to octane
settings and you change your when you're
in path tracing here you go to octane
settings and you set your GI clamp to
one it starts out at like a million like
this but if you take that to just one
it's gonna clean up your scene really
nice also if you want to go a little
further make an octane camera throw a
camera tag on it and if you take this
hot pixel removal right here under
custom LUT under camera imager you
should be able to just drag that slider
down and it's gonna get rid of those
fireflies for you but setting the GI
clamp to one that's the way to go
okay so Chazz Billy asks have you have
you do you have any tips on how to keep
motivated and create scenes so what I'm
doing now is creating a scene based off
of a description in a book so that's
something that I do to stay creatively
challenged is you know take someone
else's description from a book or
something and try and create that or if
you guys read any manga or anything or
graphic novels you can try and take a
little piece a little scene from that
and try and render it in whatever
program you're using so those are those
are a couple ways that I get past
writer's block or creative block is use
other sources of inspiration if you guys
go on walks take pictures on those walks
and maybe try and render some of the
things that you find on your walk it
could be something as simple as like a
breaker box it could be a concrete
texture you know it could be whatever it
doesn't have to be like a car or
building or anything but those things
are cool too and why is my name Punisher
so in 9th grade
maybe 8th grade me and my friends got
together we had a little wrestling match
every Friday after school at my buddy's
house and we would we were all watching
a show called puro ninja at the time
which is one of the best just one of the
best shows ever pure ownage it's about
some socially awkward gamers and um the
the main character in the game his name
was Jeremy but his like screen name was
the poner err I believe hit you know we
kind of just took that and ran so each
of us had our own name
for this little wrestling group there
was grandmaster poem maybe sensei pone
and then and then I was the Punisher so
that's how I got my name is because I
just love Pierre ownage what a great
show
all right all right this image needs hmm
what is this image
right so Jovan says it needs story
motivation this doesn't have much story
motivation I agree with you because we
have yet to add our characters there are
two characters and that goes I think of
Ari that's most of the story are the
characters I am such a sucker for wide
screen here so maybe well maybe we do a
little bit of widescreen
1920 by 810 I believe is the 2 3 7 ratio
we're looking for let's lock that all
right that's some wide screen right
there let's zoom it out well tilt it up
a little bit
we'll move maybe we'll get this tree
more up in there I feel like the right
we're missing a little bit of stuff but
I think that's okay for now let's get
this wall going
all right so our characters we need some
characters sitting down so let me show
you guys something really cool this is
the coolest site for 3d characters if
you want to animate them as well
so let me just log in to my Adobe here
this comes free with any Creative Cloud
membership you may have or Adobe sign-in
that you have you use your Adobe account
and yeah you just scroll through a bunch
of different mocap data here and it's
loading right now but basically you have
characters and animations so we'll go to
characters and we want to find the right
character we're looking for something
realistic not cartoony so we it is it's
a cold day it's winter so we need to
find someone you know winter garb here
let's see
you can also load in your own characters
so maybe depending on what we find here
we can go to turbosquid and download a
character drop them in here and see if
we can't get them in like a seated
position quickly and I wish they'd just
I wish they had more characters
you could also grab a photo scan of
yourself um and I think there's like
actually a pretty cool resource a photo
scan to people and I'm gonna look that
up right after this but basically I
don't think there's like a snow code
person no there's not okay so let's just
save that for a second um let's see
let's go turbosquid will type in like
winter person hmm
winter people these ones okay so these
photos scans here I think there's some
free photo scans
santa claus no we don't need santa claus
photoscan person hmm
I think there's a website for like CG
people it's all free CG people what is
this oh man you probably got like
sign-in and everything huh
hmm so maybe the person side of this
thing might be a deeper dive because I
don't have the exact asset for this so
it's basically someone in like a coat
sitting down in a coat
which honestly it's probably easiest
just like photoscan myself and render
that out get that going and drop it into
the scene that's probably to be the best
bet but that's the story element cuz
basically it's the same character
talking to his shadow but it still feels
the scene still feels like I think it
definitely needs some fog I'm such a
sucker for fog let me pause the render
and add a little bit real quick I don't
think we need that much but a little
goes a long way so with fog once again
the first thing I do is set the voxel
size in the editor to 100 that way it's
not gonna break your viewer here
you know we'll just cover our scene
something like that that we can hide the
fog volume from the picture viewer here
let's give it a render it's probably to
be dark and Muskrat mike is asking if
there will be a stream with ren and
myself in the near future or has that
and pushed off with the whole pandemic
basically been pushed off for the
pandemic I still really really want to
do it and we're gonna do it as soon as
we can that's basically where it's at
right now but yeah we want to do a whole
like boss town dynamics thing for you
guys live will take like two or three
hours to do it
we're basically mocap some stuff attach
the robot to the mocap data and
composite the robot
all right well light will render well
motion track the scene and we'll
composite the robot and after-effects so
we still really want to do that but it's
just you know we've got this whole whole
coronavirus thing going right now we got
to stay safe stay smart
all right let's um let's add gonna hide
the fog for now I'm just gonna add some
detail to this little lean-to here said
it had like some random building
materials around it based on the text
here so that text says in a corner
stands lean-to of bricks and building
scraps so let's grab some building
scraps from quick soul mega scans here
this website is the best so we'll go to
3d assets we'll see what they have so
building scraps to me that's like pile
of bricks maybe some sandbags yeah we'll
grab this pile of sandbags oh my
goodness I'm out of points guys I'm out
of points oh that's horrible
Oh No okay what do I have what do I have
to work with here hmm
this dirty wooden table we could use
that let's see
we will grab this wall of sandbags here
and grab this crate here we'll export
this to our scene
we'll grab these old wooden boards of
course yeah we'll work with that man
those points went fast I just love this
website though alright so what do we
what do we have in our scene right now
what's up Peter how you doing man guys
Peter France is in the chat right now
he's the he's a blender mastermind this
dude is incredible Peter you should you
should drop your channel name here so
people can go check you out yeah Peter
is basically a prodigy a blender prodigy
yeah his his work blows me away is it's
he's just unstoppable he's got some
awesome blender tutorials
and he comes into corridor once every
year for a little bit we sit right next
to each other and talk about CG stuff
all the time so that's great I hope
everything is good for you man I hope
you're staying healthy staying safe
all right um let's see let's pause the
render and see what we got here we got
this wood container
let's grab everything else here we got
wooden boards we need those we need the
wooden table let's grab our sandbags
that should be good for now
we'll wait while everything gets loaded
in heck yeah everyone knows Peter that's
great and yeah I do need to download
unreal I need to learn it it's Oh after
that uh they really set video last year
I believe called rebirth and that thing
just blew me away I definitely needed to
download that program and learn well we
have time
sweet Peters got some fans in the chat
heck yeah
so I guess it no way there are my boards
sweet and then I still have to grab that
table doing the tables huge
all right so I'm just kind of arranging
all this stuff as I feel it would be
arranged
we're gonna take these wooden boards
here drag them up throw them in a cloner
and just drop them on the ground here so
I'll scale them up a little bit let me
close the front door real quick alright
let's throw these guys in a cloner
and if you guys remember from the 3d
compositing tutorial where we cloned all
the lettuce and dropped it on the ground
that's exactly what we'll be doing with
these boards here
just an easy way to you know get stuff
scattered around in a natural way where
is
be random yep and then let's just give
them a randomizer on rotation such as a
whole bunch of sticks
and we'll give a simulation tag rigid
body tag to the cloner and we'll select
the ground the table the sandbag these
boxes and this wall will give those a
simulation tag Collider body tag here
and let's just hit play and see what
happens
yep
so in the cloner rigid body tag we're
gonna want to change the collision from
[Music]
inherent tag set it to compound
collision shape I believe nope I think
we have to just do a ply tag to children
I lied okay individual elements
top-level there you go and let's set
bounce to zero friction to 100 let's
even go 200 so that you kind of like
stay where they are and I'll slide all
around cool extend the duration of our
scene here and then we'll basically just
freeze these guys that's fine there so
we'll select the rigid body tag on our
corner we'll go to let's see let's just
cache the simulation so we can scrub
through it and our scene and find the
best angle we want the best frame
something like that
and now let's just render that see what
it looks like cool
all right I wonder what would happen
lighting wise if we instead of using the
sunlight let's turn off the Sun and
let's get out of our camera view here's
another cool tip actually if you make an
area light and this could work for
anything by the way you make an area
light and you go to camera set active
object as camera so now you are the area
light and basically wherever you're
looking you're positioning the area
light like this so I'm just gonna do
like a top down maybe from the back a
little bit like here
so that is going to light our scene
basically with a massive area light like
this from back here and then if you just
switch back to camera view snap out of
camera view you can see our area light
is up there where we reviewing the scene
from so that's a really easy way to
position lights so if we go back to our
scene view here let's render it and see
what the area light looks like
definitely not bright enough cuz it's
tiny and it's way up there so I'm just
gonna scale it up I'm hit T click and
drag and it's gonna start to scale it up
and it's kind of giving it a nicer nicer
look let's take it down to like 50
percent this keep scaling it up and you
can see it peeking in here
so we'll click the light tag here go to
visibility and uncheck camera visible
and that gives it a bit of depth that I
that I'm starting to like right now
let's turn our fog back on and see what
it's doing and that's starting to get to
a place that I am feeling good about we
still need to surround our scene with a
fence which is gonna take some time and
we need to add the characters I think
I'm just gonna photoscan myself and put
myself in that bench but we're getting
we're about it three hours now guys I
think this might just be all the time we
have so I'm gonna keep cranking on this
thing throughout the week hopefully you
guys we're around for the announcement
here I'm issuing you all a challenge it
is a weekly challenge challenge that
will come back to every week and I'll
announce five winners the five most up
voted images so basically it works like
this doesn't matter what program you use
as long as you guys are not honor system
here and you render it looks like we're
two got a submission but the discord
server linked the discord server for
this VFX livestream is in the chat or in
the description down below basically
you're gonna go there sign up for the
server and under the streams tab we have
the one hour challenge
submission this week's submission is to
render a book okay
we already got a couple of you guys and
so Demonte one of our moderators has
dropped the rules already during the
stream so
everything is due your submission is due
by let's see next Saturday at 7 a.m.
Pacific Standard Time so I have time to
wake up and look at your images yeah
render book do it in an hour
post it to the one hour challenge
submission channel on my discord server
and I'll pick five of them the five most
up voted ones here and I'll kind of just
break them down and critique them and
shout you guys out live on the live
stream
in the meantime another thing yes so on
my website noise grain and light comm
I'm running a twenty five percent off
sale only for this weekend today and
tomorrow you know all of these images
here super high quality prints they are
archival print quality that means it's
not gonna fade none of that stuff ship
it out pretty quick as well get it to
you guys ASAP yeah I'm getting these
prices down as low as I can for y'all
well you guys are in quarantine maybe
get yourself something nice to hang up
on the wall and look at the pictures are
from all around the world film and
digital but yeah for today and tomorrow
only I got all images 25% off for you
guys so check it out no he's grain and
light calm slash shop will get you there
I think that's everything I look forward
to taking a look at your guys's book
renders and I'll keep cranking hello
Gilbert
I'll keep cranking on this image here
throughout the week and I'll see you
guys in the discord server I'll be there
pretty active yeah it's been fun thank
you guys
can newbies join of course newbies can
join that's a little point guys we're
we're here to learn and grow together
doesn't matter how new you are to this
thing doesn't matter how advanced you
are but thank you guys so much for
joining thanks for sticking in and I'm
gonna keep working on this image I will
post updates on the the discord server
for you guys so stay safe and stay
healthy and I'll see you guys next week
peace